I think it's one of the ones that I
don't know hi I'm Ferran
hi I'm destiny and today we're going to
be trying to identify European languages
I feel 50/50 on this like I think I can
get the big ones but if you're throwing
some like obscure country at me then I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to do it
like someone from Croatia like I don't
know what that sounds like we do Italy
Spain France I can think I can get those
I like when I say teeny tiny teeny like
a couple words a French but that's
really good like so small I don't speak
any languages I took Spanish in high
school and then I immediately forgot
Spanish once I left high school so
that's a no for me I have never been to
Europe so I'm really excited to go on a
sensory journey today and hear these
languages and see if maybe I can pick up
something before I go I guess we're
gonna put on blindfolds to heighten our
senses my senses are already heightened
tight yeah I can hear them already
outside the door or then this is equal
opportunity right here in ent meter
evoke we in Macedonia
Josaphat ozone a tirado year Isaiah led
a CDS era al aeropuerto LAX stava casa a
casa
miss Rosa dutiful Ariel Sharon be back
on Tommy
Kaneesha delaria Palmilla Palmilla dos
appeared English kevo in yeah cousin
magical time
Tom possibly take whatever Oliver G boy
separated and killing what's up Earl and
overall I'm thinking somewhere like
around Spain or Portugal at first I
couldn't tell there's lots of like Z's
in there and I'm like okay where we go
in but then it kind of was like rolling
off the tongue so I was like it kind of
sounds a little like Spanish II but
we're talking Europe so I was thinking
like Portugal destiny this will really
help us
can you say no in your language no
Dustin you got it ready all right cool
house here my answer Spain I will also
say fate hello hello how's it going good
my name is Massimiliano oh no and I am
from Spain just kidding I'm from Italy
well it was a pleasure thank you for
coming and we voted for the little ball
aha
yo f Ronit land long scope in order they
valid collet okay valid for men who the
reference value at going on and on
stands to Miller Buddha a friendly
little on Minda and album Ileana for
Tony Lara tricky yeah it Nicki alcohol
I mean are very tricky schnapps well
then weld it in the bottle said corty
you love us on MonaVie filler are under
Borah on the Borah hell dog are the
member are super super teaspoons be
Morrison Walkman board with the paragon
Oberon neuter of them Fitness so cool
and yet the Kelty and proven turn
Diamond Bora Yama she threw him a tricky
one for cloud that was a lot of words
and sounds I I have some ideas I have
some ideas but I'm not I am Not sure I
first I was kind of like a Greek ish but
then I was like maybe like Jack or like
Russian I don't really I cannot I think
it's one of the ones that I don't know
yeah which is all of them did you say
Underberg at one point in the ball oh
that's not right mm-hmm alcohol okay I
think I would guess you're gonna go weak
no no I'm gonna go with
Russian Russian actually way way way no
can you say like my name is you don't
hit that I don't know
Rick Rick Frick Frick do I have to make
a guess I don't know polish I don't know
I said slow back that was Swedish Wow
Oh for to folk over to again lovely
let's just go say another yeah take the
blindfold off
he's right that's right great
well all right we tried okay anyone else
ever guesses that correctly my best
friends think I'm making it up on the
spot
Alam Nina's Elsa why not your sort of
protocol Oh - no I dispersal mechanism
agenda seeing Queen Vera a nurse in
cream democracy Nazir disorders eaten my
vvm with Stephanie capital to Gaza
understood idea it's almost fresh kid
vidi-vidi
- that represents our key stats on
leaders
he owns a new the affirmative sons
become you know do basic events for a
vid para Keith you're Stephen padalka
Mia famiglia
Posada natal you were know Lou if judge
you if returned to Chikara through the
manga yours - na bakke some of what she
was saying
kind of sounded a little like some could
be similar to Spanish a little bit but
also not so I'm still trying to piece
together what she just said I'm gonna
just say Portugal cuz I'm really feeling
that I think that's I think that's what
I'm getting here can you say like I eat
fish elcome face well now that Ferran
said that now I'm kind of like yeah but
also can you say
I went to school today if we press call
it was damn Portuguese sounds like now
that I mean I don't know what it sounds
like but nothing fairness said that I'm
like leaning into it but I also like I
also sounds like it could be East you
say but I'm like you - you picked that
we'll split the difference you take one
over there and I'll take Portugal and
we'll just call it even if one of us say
I like dogs
it was just the case no no nevermind
hold on I'm feeling like bang bang yeah
that's what I'm feeling something around
that area well now I don't know because
that I like dog I like dogs is like that
threw me a little bit that's not what I
was expecting
I'm just gonna stick with it I'm over
three already are all four - already
let's just go over three I'm gonna lock
it and finally answer Portugal pravin
intros are pick RHA Cato da da da a V
Mancari buna she Monte no she's in
through mosh implied she is pendrick is
the totem for soiree she charged with us
on my spoon Simon Kamata Carla and
sarama she came important to Luke Roja
Damon personage short important tano
poses phenom la estan personage career
sujets enjoy I'm thinking like initially
I want to say like Russian or something
like that
but I also don't know I don't know
either
it also kind of has like a Spanish II
sound to it but honestly her cadence is
like very smooth but it kind of sounds
like a little bit like French a little
bit like I'm getting something
times but I don't know the French that
like I was taught like doesn't sound
yeah that's like some of the words she's
saying I'm like wait can you say like my
name is no melimeli esta oh boy this is
Hans is so hard you guys but that's on
my board base cassava root on peak oh
yeah okay mm-hmm yes the property
Frances's Espanola yes Anna charge
familia limbo since chin chilling
Rochester Lucchino let you have the
floor no wait I just need like a second
let me think through I'm like looking at
a map in my head it's okay go you should
go with Greek you know Greek honestly
I've been holding out to say Croatian so
maybe I'll just use that now say yes I
am hungry da mr. Forman then nevermind
I'm gonna say Russian I'm gonna just
jump right on in and say like finish so
it's Romanian by you both clothes
because Romania it's part of these five
Romance languages so it's French Spanish
Italian Portuguese and Romanian it's the
only Eastern European country that has
the most language so you can feel a
little bit of Russian but also the Latin
so yeah because we have da but we have
that I've never heard Romanian before I
think I have heard Romanian before I'd
never thought anything of it so that's
probably in Vampires movies there's
always a lady or the bad guy the vampire
like that alpha vampire I said something
cool movie Fiona and blah blah blah or
something yeah yeah this the DA really
threw me
it sounds like Russian done
I clearly did not do well at all that
was it's really hard because I feel like
a lot of languages or like have pieces
of other like you know yeah I'm like
there's it's just it was really hard
yeah like especially with the last one
where she was like yeah it's like a
little bit of Spanish and a little bit
of French and a little bit of this and a
little bit of that and so we were
listening we're picking up on all those
things but it was really hard to
pinpoint sort of like which direction
that it was leaning and learned I'm
terrible at languages yeah I learned
[Music]